he's in a box look at him he's in a box
he's downstairs in a box on the floor
near the shelves
serious go down there and work your
magic
hey where are you
yeah we were supposed to meet here
what
oh my gosh
that ties in perfectly with something
that Michael was telling me earlier
I just don't know what some of the
people in like accounting are gonna do
it said specifically that
no
this is the forklift you need you need a
license to operate this machine that
means the upstairs office workers can't
drive it quiz Mike should you drive the
forklift I can and I have no no no no no
no I said should you you should not
drive it you should not drive the
forklift you're not allowed to dry the
forklift it's not safe you don't have a
license guys I'm not the only one who's
driven the forklift Pudge has driven the
forklift match
I thought your name was budge no it's
always been managed okay
um her her yes her is qualified to work
a dangerous machine you are not
okay all right fine do you understand
that yes we do safety training every
year or after an accident
we've never made it a full year
this particular time I was reaching for
a supply box on the top shelf
when one office worker who shall remain
nameless
kicked the letter from under me and
yelled hey Daryl how's it hanging
and I fell and busted my ankle
I'm legitimately scared for my workers
I wish I was there to see his face when
he gets to the end and finds them
fake Grail
no ground you don't remember I don't
an X
Annex
it must open something in the annex oh
seat
entrance
what that's a flush
there's nothing down here oh
I expected more from Young Albert this
just
forget it forget it
foreign
[Music]
have you ever been in a gang why
it's an advice question and if you don't
want to talk about it I completely
understand it's um no no no I know it's
very very personal so um
I knew it okay
what are we talking about here
Crips Bloods both God Michael oh
you ran over me with your car
you posted a picture of my bare boobs on
the bulletin board with a caption that
said Gross well Michael you are the
reason I drink
you are the reason I live to forget
[Applause]
it
what's the end of an era
you did a good job buddy now it's time
to come home
I remember when that balloon went up
there
I was still with Gil
we were so happy
when that went up there I had hair like
Rapunzel
how long do you think it's been up there
Kevin
I just remember pushing aside my silky
bangs to say
look a balloon
my Warcraft Clan was still on speaking
terms my kid didn't have a face tattoo I
was still thinking of going back to
school and I was still just a paper
salesman
well this has been fun Pam thanks for
calling us all down here
[Applause]
hey you're gonna you're gonna hurt
yourself Mike stand clear Mike get off
of the lift please come on fine I'm fine
look
up
we'll get somebody to clean that up
we're the ones that got to clean that up
damn it Michael
we have to have this thing serviced cold
front coming into the warehouse
[Music]
ski boots
wow
happy New Year Daryl oh hey Daryl
you ever done this
I'm just gonna put this over there
this is not a good idea right here
easy that's it okay
what is this
how did those get out I'm sorry
Professor copperfield's Miracle legumes
I was in Jamaica and I got
I got it was getting dark this one night
and then
now this guy comes with like with a cart
and he's
Dwight he told me things by myself that
there's no way he could have known
that's a common swindler's trick
probably
so I buy some I turn the corner I feel
like an idiot so I go back to get my
money
it was gone
you want to sell me magic beans
correction I do not want to sell you
Professor copperfield's Miracle legumes
nice try no correction terrible try
what is going on oh hey guys why is it
forklift in the wall
why is the truck empty uh it's not
totally empty is that grease on my floor
okay
I can see why you're angry you're coming
into this cold but believe me a lot of
thought went into this and did your
brains tell you to ruin these boxes with
grease okay Daryl listen and then you
will understand
the boxes were ruined during our first
trial testing so now it's cool because
we found another use forth okay all
right that's look all we were trying to
do is we thought we could come up with a
more efficient way to do things and and
we did I don't know Jim tell them what
it's called
that's all right no Jim tell him what a
name is doesn't matter what the name is
senior lodenstein that's stupid senior
lodenstein tell him why it's called that
gym that's okay we're good now Jim tell
us why it's called senor lodenstein
porquez we Rapido okay you know what
it's been a real busy day what do you
say we put all this away let me see it
it's uh it's in beta testing let me see
it get the thing
I have One Last Wish
I would like to use the Baler no
can't let you do that Mike no problem
sorry worth a try all right Daryl said I
could use a Baler because I'm leaving no
no
all right guys well
see you later Warehouse
catch you on the flippity flip
[Music]
all right then see you guys
catch a letter Warehouse
see you on the flippity flip
catch you on the flippity flip
catch you guys on the flippity flip